hey guys so i'm here at the web 2.0 expo
and there were some people that were
like what is that what is 2.0 well
you want to find out let's find out
she's stuck so i don't know what karen's
doing i have no idea what she's doing
where are we right now what poop
what's going on here
um basically it's a bunch of websites
that's what it is
a bunch of them
we're a project sharing website and so
we ever have everything from food like
chocolate truffles i'm here at the
instructables booth and i'm gonna get my
other flip camera etched with their logo
oh boy
oh my goodness
smells like burning plastic thank you so
much
this guy's driving this truck
actually i'm driving it with my mind
you're a liar
have i fallen into yeah well
it's the software that runs response
we all work for nokia okay and the
software platform is called s60 and
that's
and part of what we support in the
platform is ways for software developers
to do cool stuff on top of the phone
she would like to buy the card
five million dollars
look this up on the internet okay
shake eraser eraser yeah if
you google shaker eraser you'll find a
link to the guy andreas from austria
wow he helped us he helped our demo as
he built his truck
really cool websites here
and there's so much fun t-shirt there's
this really cool t-shirt that i got here
t-shirt
i really want a free t-shirt
karen where can i get a t-shirt really
loved a t-shirt
i did i found the t-shirt
it was even too big for me
you could fit three of you in there
three one two three i just eat
do you guys know where i am right now
i'm at the flip office